2018 foi a tomorrow dos anos meu
amigo gay 2018 pô a greve dos
caminhoneiros falando assim a gasolina
vai aumentar o Caminhoneiro de sal
mental que era você sendo
cancelado e as coisas parado e o show
nenhum funcionário e era protesto era o
povo correndo e é bala negada bala sai e
ninguém sabia que gasolina fazia tanta
falta chegava nos único impostos que
tinha gasolina o carro fala é r$ 30 é
Mili tre- trezentas eu não tenho r$ 30
senhor Eita não vai andar de carro né e
os caminhoneiros que ninguém presta
atenção Todo mundo começou e os
caminhoneiros são eu mesmo Parei de
assistir Game of Thrones Comecei a
assistir siga bem caminhoneiro cara e os
vô sendo cancelado e as pessoas no
aeroporto não acredito que perdi meu voo
para a Orlando estava louco para comer
no Camilo é o lugar do meu carro na
gente tocar mas que botei mas tem só
lento vamos